okay hello and welcome to our talk when
we're going to tell you about how we
applied the transformer architecture for
a learning to rank problem so we both
work in Allegro enhancing machine
learning ranking and here we want to
share a story about one of the
experiments that we that we did on this
on this journey ok let's start by
introducing what actually learning to
rank is so it is a field of machine
learning where we are interested in
optimizing and total utility of some
list of items for the user so we need to
sort some lists of abstract items it can
be text documents it can be products in
an e-commerce shop so that they they are
presented in the order that would
satisfy the user when when when he would
look at those ideas and to make it a to
put it into a supervised learning regime
we need a data set where we have query
and along with each item retrieved for
this query we have a relevance label for
for this item and this item relevance
can be expressed either as a created one
or a binary one in a credit case we
usually have some scale like from 1 to 5
for every document and those data sets
are usually created by human annotators
so they are usually clean and but on the
downside they are small expensive and
static so they don't
for example follow are the the things
that are going on in the culture in the
India for example product space for
binary relevance
we usually get the labels from for
example click through logs from search
engine and although it is not a direct
relevance signal we treat it as a proxy
for relevance because users may have
clicked some documents
not because it was relevant but because
like by pure chance or like going
thinking that well okay Google or
something shall be this item here so it
is probably relevant I will take a look
this kind of data is cheap to collect we
can have lots of them but it's noisy
okay so this is an example of how we
collect implicit feedback data from
search logs so we collect all the items
that were displayed on some on some
search results along with the query
along with who the user was and we
convert the items to some feature
vectors and collect actions taken by my
users so ever it was clicked skip maybe
purchase maybe some other action and
most ranking algorithm fall into the
category of score and source type so we
actually don't learn a ranking function
as a whole but we learn a scoring
function so that it will assign a
numerical score to every item and then
we will just sort it in a descending
order and if you cannot think about how
this could be done in another way one
example is a sector state algorithm
which is an iterative process at and at
each stage it just points to one of the
items that are candidate items and say
okay this will be on the top and in the
next step it will just speak the next
one from the remaining set so this this
can be done in a different way although
it is not that common okay if we have a
scoring functions just like apply it for
everything and sort it okay before we
dive how to solve this problem let's
think about the metric and the usual the
most popular metric for evaluating
ranking is normalized discounted
cumulative gay-related ascend ECG so two
kind of defect this this metric let's
start from the end so the gain we get
gained from every relevant document that
is on the list its cumulative because we
accumulate the relevance is for every
document
for from starting from the top positions
it's discounted because the value of the
cane is discounted by the position out
on which this document appears in the
final list and so here you can see on
the figure on the right its
NDC G for a listening as a function of
the position of the only relevant
document so if we would have just one
relevant document the NDC G value would
be would be high only for only if these
documents ends up in the top positions
top top view positions and the CG is
usually used with a cut off so that it
stated NDC G at five it means that we
just look at top five positions and we
don't care about the rest are the
normalizing here is to account for that
different listings have different
lengths and different number of relevant
documents and if we normalize it by the
maximum value of discounted cumulative
gain we get a measure between zero and
one for every item list okay so we want
to train our model that maximizes this
kind of metric and we would like to do
it with a Creighton based optimizer but
this metric rely on the sort operator so
we need to first sort by this course and
this one is not differentiable so it's
an active area of research to find a way
to maybe approximate this metric or do
some other trick to like directly solve
this task for format for the final
metric but in the meanwhile all the loss
functions that are used are surrogates
for the target metric so they actually
don't guarantee to optimize and ECG they
optimize something else which is or
prevents to some extent or
experimentally confirmed that it helps
in increasing ranking metrics as well so
in point wise settings we have a loss
that is defined for a single item think
about that like a classification model
whether it was clicked or not that's
that's just it
simplest case in a pairwise settings the
loss is defined for pair of items so we
take two items we like pass them through
as road weights network for example and
compare the scores and we we just want
that the scores are in the proper order
but we we look at pairs at the same time
there are just person and there are
leastwise metrics and one of them is
list net where we treat where we treat
scores we convert this course to the
probability distribution of which
document will be the top one and we
minimize a cross entropy between this
distribution and the distribution of a
grant true taken from the grant through
labels so it like takes the whole list
at at the same time it doesn't look at
the particular scores of the documents
okay okay so now that
Tomic has already taught you a few
things about learning to rank I'd like
to show you the basics of transformer a
neural architecture that we used in our
learning to rank neural models so
transformer is a neural architecture
that was first introduced in attention
so you need paper in 2017 and has since
become the state of the art in NLP in
machine translation for example the
thing that it introduced was processing
whole sequence at a time so you may
recall RNA and cell STM's and so on they
have that sequential nature right is so
they are difficult to paralyze they are
slow to train and infer wave and they
have these record dependencies so
there's exploding convention grating
problem a transformer while attacking
this problems very well it allows for a
contextualized and positional
representation using attention mechanism
which is very important here and
positional embeddings and transformer as
a whole consists of encoder and decoder
blocks we make use only of the encoder
block because we aren't used we aren't
doing this typical sequence to see
we only need to score the items so
encoder is okay here okay so I've told
you that attention is key to the
transformer architecture right so it
provides the contextual awareness when
processing a sequence element so if we
look at the output of off transformer
every output position depends on the
whole input sequence and that's what the
attention brings here so to look at it
from a more theoretical side let Q K and
V be query key and value matrices and
these are somewhat abstract entities
these are not your search queries or key
value pairs in some dictionaries they
are more abstract matrices so please do
not confuse them with anything else they
can be somehow transfer and transformed
outputs of a neural encoder or somehow
transform features in our data set
that's that's irrelevant here so what an
attention mechanism does scale dot
product attention in particular is that
it compares a key that is associated
with a particular position in the input
sequence it compares it with queries of
all the items in the input sequence
compares using scale dot product so we
get an exactly n dot product values that
we later a scale by square root of the
of the dimensional here of the vectors
we apply softmax so we get a probability
distribution over the position of over
the positions and later we just multiply
these softmax
output with the value matrix so that
every output vector depends on the whole
input sequence right and a generic
scalar product attention actually isn't
used in transformer much simpler variant
is used here a self attention so query
key and value matrices in transformer
are equal to each other or maybe linear
transformation of the same matrix of the
matrix of input features or or output of
previous and colorblock so in
transformer actually we apply different
sets of learned linear projections to
what goes into the motor the attention
layer where different sets consisting of
the query transformation matrix key
transformation matrix and value and
transformation matrix and we can have
quite a lot of these sets to capture
different aspects of the input sequences
and combine them into some resourceful
representation so that may be one one
set of these matrices tracks the price
of the items may be another it tracks
the visual aspects and so on and the
output of these this particular
attention blocks can be concatenated
into a multi-headed attention output and
the final transformer encoder blocks
looks like this is it consists of two
parts a multi-headed attention part in a
fully connected part is very simple with
the only thing that is maybe it may be a
little different from from some basic
intuition is that it has dropout it has
dropout mechanism and and the residual
connection and layer norm but other
other than that is just multi-headed
attention followed by a fully connected
layer okay let's now think how to
combine both both of these things so now
if you haven't been familiar with the
transformer or the self attention
previously I can now give you in like a
conceptual example of what what we get
with it so this is how we apply it for a
list of documents here we have a list of
products in some shop so they are passed
as an input to the in to the set of
encoder blocks and what we get in effect
is that after first encoder block the
representation of
it's a first product here it's not just
transformed this representation it
included as well what other items are
presented on the same list so imagine
that a book costs like cost something
and probably to let the model kind of
get a good score for this for this book
we would like to think whether it was
presented along with more expensive
books or maybe along with much cheaper
books so for example this is what we
what we get from applying self attention
to the list of to the list of products
and we stuck a few encoder blocks and
finally we end up with a movie score and
you like normally do sort sort by this
course and when training we use those
scores we apply some loss function on
that and we train it so that good items
have high scores okay but in a real
world environment we we would love but
we cannot apply this kind of
architecture for like all retrieved
items for some query it can be thousands
of them so what happens usually is a
kind of a cascade ranking where we have
multiple stages of ranking each one is
limiting the number of processed items
so we start with like all of them then
we take like top top and and then at the
end we just take top K for example to
present to the user this is the quality
versus efficiency trade-off here yes we
can we can take more but it will take
more time to to make a prediction the
latency will will go up but
unfortunately in a normal setting the
self attention is invariant to the order
of items so it doesn't matter if you
shuffle them before you pass them to
this to this network so we kind of
cannot use the the information the prior
that you have that well those items were
at the top and this one were actually
the first so the the basic rancor would
would put this item as at the first
position so to kind of account for that
a positional encoding was introduced
together with this architecture where we
where we like combine features of of an
item with some vector that is
representing a position it can be either
a fixed one it can be learned doesn't
matter for now we just here we just sum
sum them sum those vectors into one and
we kind of have a mixed representation
and coding both an item and E and its
position the example here covers like
words in our case it would be products
this picture comes from the Illustrated
transformer guide which is like a great
resource for you if you want to like
look at by example how does the
transformer work so we recommend it okay
so now you're pretty familiar I think
with with the transformer with our model
they are quite simple
so we'll describe all these experimental
results and that we got during during
our project so let's begin with the data
sets so a stomachs set at some point
data sets in learning to rank come in
two main flavors these are there are
these data sets that have items
relevance graded by experts and there
are these data sets that contain
implicit feedback which is noisy and so
on difficult to work with so we've got
this standard LTR evaluation data set
called web 30k it consists of 30,000
queries from a being search engine it's
supplied by Microsoft the items
relevance was grated by experts and the
relevancies are pretty dense definitely
not not sparse defense there are
numerous examples of queries where there
are like almost every items relevant at
least to some extent and we've got our
own dataset in-house data set consisting
of search logs there are 1 million
queries now so we've got this implicit
feedback which is noisy and difficult to
work with but we somehow managed to
to get it done here and the relevance is
our binary and sparse this is especially
important because not every loss
function will apply here
so before I start describing the results
let's talk a little bit about the table
the results for web 30k are reported as
NDC G at 5/5 position we compare our
self attentive model with MLPs
with a similar number of parameters I
think that in most cases the number of
parameters was actually bigger than in
the self attentive case also we supply
results of an extra boost gradient
boosting model so using any loss we get
better results for the self attentive
model than for the gradient boosting
model and and for and for the ML piece
only one MLP is worse that then the
gradient boosting model was also
important here and another interesting
thing about this table is that well
we've got like seven seven different
losses here some of them have real nice
theoretical properties like and
acidulous two plus plus it's a ranked
and variant I would I won't go into
details but it's proven to be a pretty
tight bound of and of actual non
differentiable and ECG but still a loss
that has no actual connection with the
industry at least not any explicit
connection where with the NDC G performs
better and it's ordinal loss based on
and generic or the ordinal regression
task so this is web 30k and we've got
our cells look the lobby's data set the
results are reported here as NDC G at 60
position improvements over the
production ranker we cannot disclose our
production rank or details here as well
as the baseline results so not every
loss function applies to binary
relevance cases so there are four loss
functions left emilp is no longer
surpass XD boost because it's much more
difficult setting
which I think that MLPs
cannot really work with here and waited
rank net variants are versatile and
effective these are lambda rank and n
deciduous to plus plus and recall that
rank net is a loss function that was
first developed in like 2005 and the
technology is still very very effective
and is going strong so okay these are
the results and the main technical part
of our presentation is done now but we'd
also like to show you our latest release
our latest open source release in the OL
rank that we used to prepare all these
results so we provide an open source
implementation of our transformer based
model a whole LTL pipeline ready to work
with and the rich set of loss functions
on our github account the framework is
based on PI tours so most of you will be
familiar with it and it comes with a
handy getting started guide that will
kick start any LTL project be it
research or commercial one and we will
share it with you under Apache License 2
2.0 and you can use all ranked in a very
very easy way the only thing you
actually need to supply for for the
basic use case for LTR experiments is
JSON file containing training config and
the dataset path and the data set needs
to be structured in a mmm in an lib SV
informant so we need to tell the the
framework how many transformer blocks to
use where the data data set is located
what optimizer to use and so on it's
also possible of course to use the auto
rank building blocks in a custom
fighters pipeline you may only use for
example the loss functions whatever you
want so I strongly encourage you to try
all ranked if you ever have some LT ur
needs we will surely try to develop is
develop it as much as possible but
another thing that we're going to do in
the nearest future is that will bring
our neural models into production
and while our work is this research site
will also conduct some some experiments
ranging from LTL theory to novel data
approaches there are some some fields in
alt here that are especially interesting
right now so this is an TCG optimization
by bound versus direct approximation via
approximate sorting operators there is a
multi-modal ranking where we can use for
example the raw image data or row sound
data to recommend for example music
track source or something like that and
there's ranking diversity it's
especially important because well we
want to satisfy every customer not here
not only your average customer so we
need to supply diverse rankings that
will satisfy a broader range of
preferences so that's all and thank you
very much also this paper I wouldn't
have happened this this work wouldn't
have happened if not for the amazing
team behind it
consisting of these people and thank you
for your attention
hopefully not self attention unless your
transformers
thank you for your talk and now
questions very nice results
congratulations can you explain what are
the features that are input to this
model yes certainly
well it depends on the data set at the
web 30k data set contains I don't
remember exactly but like almost a
hundred or maybe so features that mostly
come like they are like aggregated
values of like tf-idf for this document
weighted by something they are quite
they are described but they are not not
not raw they did that there was a lot of
feature engineering done dead there and
for our in-house a dataset we like
cannot enclose everything but those are
like the things that we can collect
about about the offers how how are they
clicked how cute is their ID no photo
how cute is the quality of the of the
server yeah so like there are numerical
features in there like couple of them
not not that many next question hello
thank you for talk and I have a question
I guess you compared the transformer
waddle with MLP and Curtin correct me if
I'm wrong but you can purge just with
normal fully connected Network yes yes
so I'm not very familiar with the
ranking models but is there any other
architectures based on neural nets like
more advanced and using more novel
architectures like CNN for example
because you compare transformer with
very weak and general fully connected
Network okay I see your point
well
I think that here it's it's like the
choose of forward Network or was just
due to the fact that we process
numerical features of course those that
transformer would be applicable to like
texts or images data if we provide a
proper encoder for example based on the
convolutional network or some other four
texts or the orders but it's not about
the ranking as a task that would require
this architecture it's more about the
data that you process that like forces
you to use convolution as or RNN there
are models that use RN ends here one of
them is the sector state but they don't
give very great results and they are
quite hard to train but it's like more
focus on what data we process not the
ranking task okay it's hard to implement
the algorithm data for us in user do you
need to retrain the model no we don't
need to trained model but it would as
well depend on how would you represent a
particular user in in those experiments
the user was though like a single entity
anywhere in the model so it was user
agnostic it was a general model it was
not personalized if you would like to
personalize it you did to somehow
account for that but still there is
nothing that requires you to do it in
the way that it would need to retrain it
for for every for the next user ok got a
question
hi can you estimate what is the business
value what is the business impact of the
new model on four Allegro in general
well a tough question let's say that it
is a model that will like work in the
wild for like ranking and queries that
will be to come so we don't know what
they are but what is usually on we the
evaluation that showed is based on a
kind of it's called off policy
evaluation so we take the historical
interactions and we kind of simulate
okay what would happen if we would apply
this model to the data is that how we
get these improvements etc and like
previous experiments with other models
proved to us that they the offline
simulation results are correlated with
online results so what happens if we
really deploy this model and as well we
showed some correlation of like this
metric that we want to optimize with
some more business-oriented metrics like
you know conversion etc but you know
that's the thing that we cannot go into
like digits Thanks okay maybe one more
question okay so thank you once again